foreign
[Music]
hello my name is Matt flickel and today
I'm going to be talking about methods to
avoid some of the common or less common
study pitfalls with in Vivo studies
um by way of background I've been
working in the laboratory animal
research field for about 31 years now
and I have been running teams and
departments who focus on this work for
about the last 17.
so I'm going to start a little bit
differently
um because I'm going to start with a
case study
this is an illustrative case study so
it's one that I worked on about 20 years
ago
um but it incorporates a lot of
let's say the concepts or the ideas that
can cause these studies to go off the
rails
I'm going to be talking about a ferret
radio telemetry model that I worked on
there was a really interesting model it
was also one of the most frustrating
models I've ever worked on
um
but it was really important right
because
especially at the time this was when
the Regulatory Agencies were primarily
focused on
QT so a segment of the ECG prolongation
as an indicator of sudden cardiac death
um
and so that was one of the absolute Key
Safety pieces for any drug going to
Market is do you have any QT segment
liability and if you do you're probably
not going to Market
and so the project that was put in front
of us is how do we do that as soon in
the developmental process as possible
because you don't want to find out when
you've just spent 150 million dollars
that oh well here's a liability how do
you push that forwards you don't waste
resources be they people's time be they
the lives of laboratory animals how do
you answer this question as quickly as
possible
and so we looked at that and we went
yeah that should be doable
um it's an established study design
we've run that in any number of lab
animal species it's an established
procedure we know the devices we know
how to place them it's an established
technology it's just putting it into a
new species
so this should be straightforward and it
should take about two to three months
um if you look at the art down at the
bottom you can get a little bit of a
spoiler there it was not it took us
around eight months probably closer to
nine
and the first piece that it drove home
is different species have very different
Anatomy they have different physical and
physiologic responses and those make a
huge difference and I should have known
better but I didn't
so why were we doing this and this is
important because I'm going to talk
later about why having a goal and
knowing the importance of the goal is
going to be so valuable especially when
you're doing model development
because you have to know when is it no
longer worth the time and effort you're
putting in but for us it was right
because early in a drug development
phase that drug is rare it's probably
very hard to produce
it's incredibly expensive to produce
because it's labor intensive it's
literally being made by hand
so you don't have much of it it is the
scarcest resource that you have you
can't waste it
so we needed something that was smaller
than the common dogs and rabbits
because if you're dosing by a kilogram
the lighter the animal the less material
you need
so normally you would go to rodents
rodents aren't good in this case because
they don't have the primary potassium
herb channel that is indicative
of sudden cardiac death so you need
something that is going to match humans
it needs to be productive
East have a strong enough signal so
that's another problem with rodents
their heart's very small which means the
electrical signal that it sends out is
small which means if you're trying to
measure a waveform and it's tiny it's
really hard to measure it and especially
20 years ago
most of the automated systems could not
handle anything that didn't have an
amplitude above one millisecond or I'm
sorry one millivolt
and then a rodent you're looking at like
0.2 so everything would have to be done
by hand and that wasn't going to work
either
a ferret is small it's around eight nine
hundred grams so much smaller than a
rabbit or a canine
we've worked with it in research as a
model for a very long time so we know
how to work with them we know the
husbandry requirements we know what kind
of enrichment they need we that is well
understood and as a bonus
when you do that initial herc Channel
assessment in vitro so tabletop you're
using typically purkinje fibers from the
heart of a ferret so from a regulatory
standpoint there's already some buy-in
that they're the right model because you
can point to it and say well if those
can purkinje fibers that we're looking
at are good enough for the in vitro work
well then they've got to be good enough
for the in Vivo work as well so they
seemed ideal
um
and they were just not from a
development phase
so here's the big reason so a ferret
runs anywhere from seven to eight
hundred grams to 1.1 to 1.2 kilos which
is a heck of a lot smaller than a rabbit
or a canine but for their body size they
have an enormous heart when you're
measuring the electrical activity of the
heart the bigger the heart in relation
to the body the bigger the signal
amplitude so the easier it is to read
that signal and measure it
and we encountered a whole host of
unexpected things
the first is
you have to cannulate an artery you put
a pressure cannula in place to be able
to measure the blood pressure you want
an arterial line
usually that's fairly straightforward
but unfair it wasn't lots of fat lots of
fibrous tissue and it wasn't easy to
dissect
and in this case the fibrous tissue that
we were trying to work through was
actually far Tougher Than The Vessel we
were trying to gain access to and that's
problem because
the thing we most wanted to keep intact
was the one that was most likely to fall
apart
they also had some additional things so
standard transmitter is based off
standard in this case rodent
ferret is much longer than a laboratory
rat or a laboratory Mouse and so the
various catheters and ECG leads weren't
long enough so we had to work within
that too but the good news is
the ECG waveform was so strong that we
actually had to move to pinpoint
electrodes because a normal ring Loop
picked up so much signal that it
actually obliterated what we were trying
to look at so that was a good sign it
was actually going to give us what we
needed
however
first thing to keep in mind with
these types of animals is
whatever you do whatever model you
create it has to work for them when
they're doing normal movement and we
picked the animal that ties itself in
and Knots literally ties itself into
knots
turns its torso 360 Degrees around from
the hips so a lot of movement so
everything we put in there had to be
able to hold up to animals that move
like this
and if you look down in the bottom left
hand corner that's what happens when you
put a standard polyurethane pressure
cannula in an area that crosses the hip
in a ferret just like if you take a wire
and you bend it repeatedly until it
starts to become brittle it's exactly
what happened here it actually caused a
change to the crystalline structure of
the plastic
so that wasn't going to work so the
standard move to ephemeral artery have
your transmitter placed subcutaneously
didn't work
fair enough
so
when we moved then into the body core
again fairly common approach use that
for rodents all the time because their
peripheral arteries are too small to
cannulate
we found some more unexpected things
right because the animals that we work
with they don't necessarily read the
anatomy textbooks and so in this case
one of the things we found not
represented in the textbooks or
literature is it roughly one out of
every four ferrets we worked with didn't
have one aorta they had two of them um
they were bifurcated running in parallel
additionally also atypical the aorta
itself was extremely fragile and filled
with various uh branches coming off of
it
so because of that we had to use some
rather different techniques to avoid
damaging the aorta having it tear but
also to occlude off all of those
branches so we could isolate a segment
so if you look in the lower right
we went over to a CO2 surgical laser to
make that arteriotomy so make the
incision in the artery and then also
both myself and the other surgeon had to
grow additional arms with all of the
different swabs and instruments that we
had to use to gently push down and all
of that collateral circulation to keep
that area clear of blood
but so we had multiple surgeons Now new
approaches that we've never used before
and the introduction of that CO2 laser
and it still didn't work
over 90 percent of those cannulas failed
within six weeks and what we found is
that
again going back to the animals move
around a lot and they're pulling on all
of this Hardware
they expelled the catheters from the
aorta something I've never seen before
in any other lab animal species
um and it wasn't one or two it was nine
out of ten literally pushed them out of
the aorta walled them off with scar
tissue and no catheter or at least the
catheter was no longer transmitting a
signal
but we were close right and so we
modified the catheter attachment with
pulley suture pattern we also introduced
the catheter into the abdomen a
different spot
and you got what you see here
right which is beautiful pressure waves
beautiful ECG waves
but nothing went as planned and that's
kind of where I want to start with the
study design recommendations
as soon as you work with lab animals
nothing goes according to plan you can
minimize those let's call them
um variations but you can't eliminate
them so you have to account for them
so let's talk in Vivo study design
there's unique characteristic with in
Vivo studies That You Don't See
elsewhere they use living animals
and Beyond the fact that there are
regulatory requirements there are moral
and ethical requirements for those
working with them
the animals themselves introduce
tremendous amount of unpredictability
are they going to be playful are they
going to be less playful do they want to
sleep do they not like the perfume that
a technician is wearing do they really
like the laundry detergent that your
scrubs were in all of these things are
variables and the way the animals
respond to them tend to be
individualistic
it also requires really specialized
training for the staff
um and speaking as a hiring manager I
wish there were far more people who had
this type of experience and skill set
but there aren't
and so
finding that team who really understands
what they're doing and why they're doing
it has those specialized skills
is critical and obviously that's
critical in any study that we run but it
certainly adds a level of complexity to
training those people
so you've got the variability that you
must control for
speaking as a study director
you've got to take the quirks of those
animals and how those techniques are
conducted into account
and I say must and I suppose there are
probably different opinions on that and
that's fair enough
but in my experience if you design a
study that doesn't have some inherent
flexibility
and some inherent accommodation to those
they will rear their ugly head and they
will cause you massive amounts of
problems
um
more to the point when we get into the
species each one reacts differently
a rat and mouse may look remarkably
similar but behaviorally they're very
very different
um a c57 mouse
versus a towel knockout Mouse behave
completely differently they have
different
Anatomy they have different collateral
circulation they have a different width
of their head which affects the width of
their brain so if you're trying to do an
intracerebral ventricular injection or
location is now different
um
all of these things matter so choosing
that right species and the correct
strain and having staff who understand
how to work with those species and those
strains is usually I say often but I'm
going to edit that to usually is the
difference between a successful and a
failed study even a partially failed
study
and one thing that I'll put out there
because we've probably all been burned
by this before I certainly have
especially in the in Vivo space most
papers
don't really talk about how the work was
done
they talk about the results but they
don't tell you how they did the thing
and that tends to lead to a lot of
Reinventing of the wheel
um but it also means what often happens
is people without experience in the in
Vivo space they find a paper that they
feel is reflective of what they want to
do
they don't have the background to
understand why the decisions and the
choices were made and they basically say
let's mimic this
and unfortunately and fairly frequently
there are
at best case there were decisions made
building that initial study that we
don't understand so we don't understand
why they might not be applicable
worst case scenario that study was
designed by someone who did the same
thing that you're potentially doing
right now
taking a previous study mimicking that
without necessarily understanding all
the things that come into it and that is
absolutely a recipe for failure it's a
recipe for variability it's a recipe for
things to go completely off the rails
we've all heard you know the proper
planning prevents poor performance and
that is absolutely true in here spending
some additional time planning around
these nuances
is really going to be the difference
between a successful and an unsuccessful
study
and again when we design any study
whether it's in Vivo or in vitro you're
designing them around the available
staff around the various activity
metrics you can do this many of these
activities in an hour we probably want
to give you a 10 percent you know safety
margin so you can do this many things in
this time
and individual studies are the same but
again the variability is not just the
people performing it now it's the lab
animals that they're working with and so
everything takes longer
and the more tightly scheduled your
activities are the more stressed the
people and unfortunately the more
stressed the people the more the animals
pick up on that the more stress they
become which makes things take even
longer and you can get into a really
nasty feedback loop that way
um
so your margins are going to be longer
if you're looking at a study and you
have no alternative then so be it but if
you do have an alternative and you look
and go well each of these activities
should take exactly 30 seconds so
I should be able to get three activities
done within a little over a minute
best case scenario maybe you can fairly
frequently that's not how it's going to
work out and if it was really critical
that you get data so let's take an
example I want an ECG measurement and a
pharmacokinetic blood sample at two
minutes after dosing
and I can accept a 30 second variance
and probably get an ECG waveform and I
can probably get the blood within that
30 second window so I you know take the
ECG at one minute 45 seconds after and
then I immediately start the blood
collection
but if anything goes wrong
you lose everything
so in those cases it's important to
prioritize what's the truly critical
thing
am I most interested in having a
pharmacokinetic blood sample at the two
minutes
probably actually and so let's make sure
that gets done on time and let's put
that ECG at three minutes or five
minutes or somewhere where we have
the ability to prioritize that critical
activity
um because your animals gotta say they
do
um
but there's a little bit of a secret
weapon for you when you get into this
and that's acclimation and positive
human contact because ideally you want
the animals that we're working with to
be working with us as well
and I put this out here because it's not
talked about very often
um and speaking to someone who's been
doing this in third for 30 years little
over now
um
we didn't pay enough attention to this
30 years ago absolutely did not we've
learned a lot since then we're better
frankly than we were then
um
but I will tell you from a lot of that
experience the more time you spend
acclimating the animal and providing
positive human contact the better the
study is going to go
the better acclimated the animals are
the more comfortable they are with us
so prioritizing
let's go down there and work with the
animals outside of the study let's give
them enrichment let's give them food
rewards let's give them toys that they
don't commonly have exposure to let's
hold them let's talk to them
let's you know rats love to be scratched
on top of the head they'll fall asleep
in your arm after just a few rounds of
that
um which means they're not nervous
they're not apprehensive around the
people anymore which means you want to
take them out of the cage they're happy
to be taken out of the cage
you take your blood sample and then you
give them a treat and you scratch them
on the back of the head and you put them
back in the cage well you've taken
something that could be potentially
uncomfortable for them or at least not
something that they're looking forward
to and now it's
it's best we can tell
they look forward to that activity
because of all the things around it you
know the nice thing is most of our
laboratory animals are social animals
which means they do respond to that type
of attention doesn't just have to be a
dog
could be a pig could be a goat could be
a rabbit
you may have to tailor your approach to
them and that's worth doing some
research because the way you give
positive human contact to a rabbit is
different than a rat
but there are a lot of resources out
there and if you tailor it towards that
species
it really really matters and also
scientifically matters because the less
stressed and more comfortable your
animal is
the less they're dumping stress hormones
the lower their heart rate
do you have a stressed animal the
variability goes way up
um because even if the variability alone
is bad what happens if half the animals
aren't stressed and half are but it's a
huge level of variability in your study
and I'd also point out finally those are
important to the staff as well
like we have the privilege of working
with these animals and
knowing that we value this positive
human contact that's important for the
people as well but you got a budget the
time you've got to train the people to
do it and you've got to set the
expectation that this is not a thing
that we cut this is as valuable as any
other study activity
talk a little bit about you know we're
always trying to push the envelope
um
what's your risk tolerance when you're
looking at a non-traditional study
design so you haven't found anything in
those papers you haven't done anything
that seems to answer the questions that
you now have to answer
well the Regulatory Agencies accept it
are you sure how strong your signals
that you're looking to measure are
because you need to figure that out
before you design the study to measure
them how do you power your study you
know
over the years the number of studies
I've seen where we have an N of six in
each group why because I always use six
six to eight it's my rule of thumb I
always have six to eight individuals in
any test group
sometimes that's too many and sometimes
it's not enough so picking that generic
off the shelf is not going to be your
best approach
um also means if you're blazing a trail
there's no one asked for help no one's
set the path for you to follow
um
what if the unexpected happens does it
tear apart your whole development plan
do you have a three-year plan that if
this doesn't work it all falls apart
and here's a scary thing
if you've never seen those results
before how you know if they're wrong how
do you know if you made a mistake
um so are you going to recognize those
erroneous results
bring in the ferret model thought it
would take two to three months
it took us about three quarters of a
year
um if you have that much time we
fortunately did
and then all of the various unexpected
things that come off of that
again if you're going to go down that
non-traditional design like look through
the regulatory guidance documents reach
out to the agencies they are helpful
they will talk to you
um because they don't want you to do bad
work they don't want you to waste the
lives of our animals so go to them ask
for help ask for guidance what do you
need to see
um for you set the study that I'm
working on
I've been a consultant in the past I'm
not now
um so no sales pitch here but
Consultants can be wonderfully useful
I've used them many a time
um because if I don't have
the experience in an area I would much
rather bring in someone who does have it
who can guide me so I'm not wasting time
and animals and all of the rest
um you have to do your due diligence
right because can they actually do
things that they're saying but I'd also
put out there
if you're partnering with a consultant
or a contract lab or another
pharmaceutical or what have you
and I strongly recommend don't treat
them as a gun for hire like treat them
as partners share information with them
um
again I've spent about a third of my
career in the cro space and
I've seen a lot of studies Fall Apart
and it hurts when you get to the end and
it
like you're looking at someone who's
wasted so much of their time and effort
and resources like that's not true it's
a non-trivial thing to set up those
studies
and you know that if you'd had a couple
additional pieces of information you
could have guided them into a study
design or methodology that would have
made a successful study
um but if you don't share information
nobody can help you
touching briefly on pilot studies I'm a
huge fan if you're not sure what's going
to happen don't go in to your three and
a half million dollar study do a twenty
thousand dollar study do something that
answers one specific question don't
everyone wants to get the most for their
dollar and that's fair I certainly do
but by the same token the more questions
you try and answer in a small pilot
study the more chance there is that one
answer obscures another so if you can
focus on what is the critical thing that
I need to learn and then design your
study to do that
um and again
if you'd go in that non-traditional
route and you can use these where ninety
percent of your non-traditional route is
actually using established methods
oh can I figure out how to do that last
10 percent with these pilot studies and
you will see examples your compound is
wonderful it absolutely is the most
effective compound ever seen But when
you put it in a non-human primates it
has a really pronounced thrombolytic
effect which means that isn't going to
the agencies
um you put an implant on the top of the
skull of a sheep
and you don't take into account that
sheep like to butt things with their
head so that incredibly expensive and
delicate instrument you put is now
fragments
um
you place Catherine into the intrathecal
space and it irritates the space
which means the space walls it off with
fibrous tissue in your catheter fails
we have a compound that is incredibly
toxic in rabbits
but in no other species
well how does that directly relate to
humans because it sure is heck a concern
at that point
a few random thoughts
as with any study you know I don't think
these are necessarily in Vivo specific
but
how do you recognize a study that's not
giving you what you need
and how do you set your acceptance
criteria at the beginning so you can
pull the plug because it's a lot of time
and a lot of effort has been invested
over the years by heaven knows how many
people
continuing to study after it's no longer
relevant
and you do I've been in it you get
caught up in that sunk cost fallacy
where it's like I've put so much time
and effort into this
another push and I'll be fine
but if you've already failed the study
you're not going to bring it back at
that point so how do you cut your losses
how do you recognize when it's falling
apart preferably well there's still time
to course correct but similarly how do
you recognize if it's succeeding
right do you have markers along the way
where you don't have to wait six months
for all of your data to be analyzed and
tabulated to know I think this worked
and again have you set specific goals
like
are you doing a box check exercise where
I don't actually have a goal for the
study I'm just running the study for the
sake of running the study
I'm not going to get anything useful out
of it and the Regulatory Agencies when
you do a box check study they can smell
it and they're going to look and they're
going to come back to you most likely
and say this isn't going to accomplish
the goal because he didn't answer a
question
I'm going to skim over some of this but
again
do you have a plan for your study
do you have a sketch a plan is good if
you really know what you're in for
because you can practice you can set up
your contingencies you've got Milestones
if you're not sure what's going to
happen you might want to have the
flexibility of a sketch a little harder
to hold on to
but it also lets you readjust fairly
quickly and that can be tremendously
valuable
go through the literature reach out to
your contacts
um one thing that I found in the air of
the internet that's just glorious
speaking to someone who's old enough to
have to go to Research Laboratories and
photocopy articles
well now you can probably get an email
and a phone number for the people who
wrote the article and most people are
going to be pretty giving so instead of
trying to interpret the paper if you
find the one this is the method cool
reach out to the authors they'll
probably talk to you
and they might share a lot of things
that aren't in the paper that will make
your life a heck of a lot easier
um I'm a trust but verify guy so don't
automatically trust the research and
also keep in mind as I'm sure we're also
all aware
amount of people who publish their
failures is really Limited
right so just because there's nothing in
the literature about whatever you're
trying to do not working doesn't mean a
lot of people haven't they're just not
typically going to publish it
and again when it gets to the in Vivo
space the procedures are usually either
just one sentence which doesn't help you
many times they're incorrect so the
person who wrote the article is not the
person down in the lab doing the work
and the number of times I've reached out
and got connected with people down in
the Animal Facility doing the work and
like yeah that's not actually what we
did what we actually did when it was
successful was the following
man that's invaluable to be able to talk
to those people
which brings me to the last piece the
people because they do actually kind of
matter
if you're going to get into the in Vivo
space and again
within the introspace is well
but I have found in the in Vivo space
you have to have that Network you've got
to have the colleagues you've got to
have your partners you have to have the
people to reach out to where they might
not know the person to talk to
they may well know the person who knows
the person and now you're talking to
someone who's actually done what you're
trying to do mentioned reaching out to
the authors
um I mentioned happens a lot the person
writing the paper was not the person
doing the work
and again go to the various Regulatory
Agencies go to the FDA
um
and put your plan in front of them and
take their critique to heart because
they're probably going to be the people
determining whether you accomplished
your goals or not
here's what I'm gonna
kind of get to the very end
but I've seen this a lot and price
interest full disclosure when I started
31 years ago I was a technician I was
the person down in the room doing the
work
um
they're not widgets they're really
really not they are the critical
Specialists who are going to make your
study successful or not
um
no study without them
if you want a high quality study if you
want high quality Animal Welfare
um if you want a good study
boy you need to be talking to them and
you need to be looking out for them
um because they're the ones who can give
you the feedback this great study design
it's not going to be able to be run and
here's why
people are relationship driven right and
I've I've coached study directors when I
was working on the Pharmaceuticals side
and I was coaching the sponsors who work
with cross or the small labs one of the
things I constantly hammered at was
spend some time making them feel
appreciated
talk to them if you're on site ask them
how the study's going
do you know their names again it's such
basic stuff
but
if they know what the goal of the study
is and they can provide the specialized
feedback that you wouldn't get otherwise
because they know to look for a thing
hey this is CNS drug it's going to work
in Alzheimer's and just so you're aware
the last three studies we've run we've
seen some really mild neurologic signs
but we're not expecting to see them so
we're not looking and monitoring in this
study
now you have an Engaged person who when
they're working can say I know they
didn't want me specifically to look for
this but I know it was a possibility and
I'm seeing it so I'm going to report it
and that's difference between walking
away thinking nothing appeared on the
study
and it's because he didn't tell people
to be on the alert for them
um
you want them to feel valued because
here's my litmus test
technician at least for the day and
they're driving home and it's raining
and they just want to go home and have
dinner and they suddenly have that
moment of
did I remember to fast the animals did I
prep the test material
I want them whenever it's one of my
studies to think
you know what
that's the guy who brought us in Donuts
on the first day of the study
that's the person who asks me what I
think that's the person who makes me
feel valued you know what
I'm sure I did it
I'm going to turn around and I'm going
to go check
or I think that there's something wrong
in the study protocol I'm going to
verify it
um you want them to be that engaged in
the study because I will tell you the
number of times it has saved my behind
over the years couldn't even count
so you may as well go for it again
when it gets into in Vivo work the
classic you can be fast you can be high
quality you can be cheap you can
probably only get one of those so be
careful to pick the one be realistic
make those milestones
share with your partners they're either
Partners or they're not and if they're
not Partners they're not helping you
request a review from the Regulatory
Agencies and don't overlook those pilot
studies those smaller experiments
don't
I can't tell you how many times and
sometimes it works but I can't tell you
how many times I've seen or I've been
the person who rolled the dice
and it didn't work and you would have
been a hero if it did but when it
doesn't
we're in a bad spot
so let's finish with let's go back to
the ferret piece
what did we learn what did I learn from
it
the good news is we had a development
rationale we knew what we were trying to
accomplish we had to find goals
we had investment stuff so we didn't
look
after leaping we planned and we did
things methodically
um we had that definition of when things
were going to work but we also knew how
important the study was so when we were
sitting there
occasionally for drinks after a very
long day
um
why were we doing it like why was this
goal so important
um we had that peer Network that we
reached out to because a lot of the
fixes that I described they didn't come
from our heads they came from us talking
to people who we knew who said why don't
you try this
but we also created a development plan
with we didn't have a lot of relevant
data we thought we knew what was going
to happen we did not we were arrogant I
was
um that's definition hubris I'm sure
that we're experienced enough that
nothing's going to bite us and it did
um we didn't put enough pilot work in at
the beginning
um we had too many variables in those
first studies and it made it harder to
figure out what was going wrong
um and we set our expectations way too
high we're going to be done in a couple
months this is going to be easy
like if you're emotionally expecting an
easy Road and you don't get it boy does
that knock the wind out of your sails
and with that
that's the end so
questions